dink-dink I feel like I have to welcome
back to the Julian podcast we're gonna
do it no I think this week's episode is
brought to you by farmers dog the dog
food company that makes feeding your dog
easy and delicious today we literally
just got our shipment today it is uh
human grade and tested recipes with food
sourced from small farms so you know you
can trust it's real food delicious food
for your dogs formulated specifically
for your pet
right now you get free shipping and 50%
off your first two weeks when you go to
the farmers dog.com slash annejulien or
click the link below great service also
guys post mates the best delivery app
out there we use it actually we're gonna
probably use it right after we film to
order dinner because we're on time to
make dinner I love doing dinner guys no
matter what you feel like ordering out
in the world do with post mates ok it's
the best way to get your food delivered
hands down the best delivery app there
is we've used it for years and we love
it right now postman is giving you $100
so free delivery credits for your first
7 days to start download the post mates
app and use code Jen and Julian that's
just our names mm-hmm thank you sponsors
and so my beep just napping on his
pillow
he's a good boy she likes the spot now
here you want me to turn him around so
y'all can see well what what I do
there's a keyboard here that controls
the recording of the audio marbles
almost turned it off now you can look at
the Bob while he sleeps cuz he's a very
gentle little made me what okay
sneeze Julianne it's gone there's one
thing that I I've done a couple times
and I don't ever do any more cuz I know
how mad it makes you but it's when when
you're about to sneeze and you're like
you're doing this you know and it's
really common and I'll say bless you and
then you won't have to sneeze you're
just it's so rude
rude boy is rude and you're a rude boy
I'm not a rude boy yes you are no I just
did a couple times as a meme but I real
opal times yeah I didn't I didn't do it
after that one time that you didn't like
it what is that what do you guys have
what is that hey hey what is it a red
piece of plastic oh god he's such a rat
had there like face inside their bed
like I thought it was like a food or
something what you said you look like a
rat stop acting like one
well cuz we had him in the car and we
were just driving like literally a
hundred feet or whatever so he didn't
you know strap them in their seatbelts
or whatever and so Kermit goes under
Julian's like seat while he's driving
because he's looking for like food
scraps like anything that smells like
food possibly in the car even though
your car's like clean he's like he knows
he's found food in seats like that in
the past he's like digging around and
that he was like going under my legs it
was really [ __ ] annoys you you
already look like a rat stop acting like
one
he's he gets nastier every day he shows
us a different level of his ability to
be just so gross and nasty all the time
I had this bed on my desk downstairs by
my PC where peach sits and she'll sit
there for hours she loves that bed she
loves she'll bark to get up and do it
yeah as Jenna says it's like the only
thing in the house that's just peachy
it's just hers and so it's her bet and
so today while I was editing I had both
of them on the bed because I was just
like I needed Kermit to be away from you
because she's worried she'll share her
bed yeah she'll share it but she's not
gonna get kicked out of her bed yeah but
anyway that's not the point you were
working I was trying to take Kermit off
of your hands cuz a lot of times when
you're writing your show or you're
working on your video whatever Kermit is
just annoying you and I know take him
away from you because he won't stop and
because he needs me every second of
every day
so I preemptively took him into the
office and had him on the bed with peach
and I was editing for like two two and
half hours and then I leave and I'm
getting him out of the bed and I see
he's like four or five just like
splotches of drool that he let out of
his mouth while leaning over the edge of
the bed onto my desk at first I was like
oh that's weird what are those drops and
then I was like that's where Kermit was
sitting he [ __ ] was sitting there
with his eyes wide like a rat open
dripping jewel out of his feral mouth
while I was sitting there idling instead
of just like sleeping or something he
couldn't just like napped it was just
thinking about what he wanted to put it
in his gullet and just drooled
have you ever drooled for food no not
for food rolled in my sleep I've drilled
in my sleep but also for food a couple
times outside of your mouth you know
it's like the food's coming like oh yeah
like that yeah it's like a natural
salivation yeah yeah it's for survival I
know I'm nasty but I'm not as nasty as
your little son yeah but we love each
other like we show all the Nessie and
all the crying we talk about it cuz it's
funny and it's like so much but like
he's my guy I know he's your guy every
second of every day together I'm very
aware he I have not walked into a room
alone since he arrived in my arms I'm
very
we can't be away from each other
he doesn't like fast movement either
well yesterday I ran through the house
to do something and he barked at me he
likely to get a package or something
yeah they hate when I run which sucks it
sucks so much because when I was a kid I
couldn't run in the house or play ball
and now I'm an adult and I just wanted
to do those things but they don't like
it so now I it's like I'm they like calm
energy Julian but I even playing ball
I'm running in the house a dog barking
at you for having energy like that is
the perfect way for you to know that
your energy is not good energy we don't
have any areas bad chaotic energy no we
don't have any areas dogs
let's get an Aries dog I don't think
that's gonna help I think they're still
gonna read your chaotic energy and react
the way the thing what okay so we're
sitting down on the dinner table okay
let me just paint a picture for you
okay I'm gonna paint it show your eyes
first guys okay where the where the
dinner table eating mm-hmm Thank You
Johnny this is your mouth oh thank you
because it doesn't make a noise at my
monitor well you think Thank You Jenna
for making dinner keep your eyes on his
water it's nice and cold ding-dong oh
let me get the door
stands up fifty dogs oh okay fine cut
out the ding-dong how about this how
about I just stand up and walk towards
the front door immediate parking that's
true sometimes they don't they pick up
on your like alertness your energy and
then they bark accordingly like to me
that's I'm not gonna discipline my dog
for barking at the door because Zoey
that's that's their job yeah no I'm not
saying plenty of people that would
disagree with me and that's fine but to
me I'd like marbles and Kermit and peach
have both peach doesn't really bark ever
tumor but like there's been plenty times
when they've alerted me to something
that I was not aware of that I'm very
grateful for fair enough I'm not trying
to say their alertness or their guard
dog mentality is bad it's just any time
I have movement that's faster than
walking about it was a Model T barked at
me when I move because I don't a chaotic
energy like you I'll tell you why they
don't bark at you because marble and
Kermit
would die for you they would both die
for you they you can do no wrong in
their eyes even when Kermit snaps at you
it's out of love hmm
me on the other hand they love me on
their dad but I'm not Jenna so I can do
wrong and in their eyes I do do wrong
when I move from there letting you know
no marbles are sleeping in front of us
and Julian just pet him like a child
wouldn't do that thing where he smiles
and now we're away from whatever just
touched him he's old you can't scare him
like that no we have it on a 45 degree
view look at this he was I saw his eye
and it was awful this was a bad
representation I'm really good with him
he we don't we get along a lot okay
we'll take your word for it
Thanks I'm sorry for startling you like
a cartoon cat do nothing if you're happy
and you give me good boy okay maybe you
stopped pushing him around the table so
he can relax I'm really sorry
anyway here's old let him [ __ ] relax
dude I'll let him relax okay well since
we had so much fun doing the first one I
don't know why it was so fun it was fun
cuz it's it's just silly and like
everyone can play along it's kind of
hard but kind of easy yes supid kind of
amazing yeah it's called guess that
recipe where we go on Pinterest and we
read the recipe allow
for the class to here and then you have
to guess what the recipe is
so I'll be like cereal milk and Jenna
will be like is it a bowl of cereal and
I'd be like yeah and that's the game so
we'll do that all right you were first
oh me Gophers are you ready yeah I still
can't get over gruel from the last time
oh I got some I got some bangers coming
this time yeah okay
Absolut bangers all right your first
recipe don't go not looking I have to
open it in Pinterest so give me a second
20 grams fresh yeast 60 grams sugar 250
milliliters milk 500 grams all purpose
flour a pinch of salt 250 grams butter
also 1 egg 1 tablespoon of milk bread
not a bad guess corn bread where's the
corn
yeah there's no corn in the corn bread
boy what's wrong with you there's no
corn and corn bread
starch or something well but there's not
literally corn in corn bread do you
wanna bet yeah what do you think's in it
corn starch yeah you think corn starch
gives it it's corn flavor no not corn
starch corn flour corn flour corn bits
look at there's not whole pieces of corn
is what your argument is you're so to be
clear your argument is that there is
full corn on cob oh yeah not one that
you bought in like a box yeah there's
like corn in there like a full cob of
corn inside I'll look up a recipe I mean
I've made it before with like actual
chunks of corn how do you bite through
it what are you talking about there's
the whole corn on the cob inside the
bread how do you eat it's not on the cob
it's not on the cob or off the cob it's
nowhere it's not even in the bread corn
there's no corn in corn bread Julian
then what's in banana bread then banana
then why isn't there corn and corn bread
there just isn't time looking up a
recipe now is now I'm just trying to
yellow cornmeal meal okay but I've made
it with corn in it before it was right
but you didn't say cornmeal I said corn
starch or flour and that's pretty much
cornmeal okay but there's cornbread that
has actual corn in it and it's so good
all plenty of those corn breads with
actual corn in it have never ever ever
made an appearance in my life I've never
seen a single corner so good what are
you crazy
you also don't like corn I love corn but
like cornbread is such a delicious food
it's like got such a unique flavor it's
like sweet but like savory like butter
on it it's so good why would you [ __ ]
put corn in it Julian its corn it's cool
okay anyways the recipe is not cornbread
but what is the rest listen this says
this calls for a four fourteen point
seven five ounces of creamed corn
creamed corn yeah okay I'll give you
that I still prefer my way it's look at
there's chunks of corn in the corn boom
instant spit out you're so rude not rude
okay anyways I give up what was that
recipe
it's a coarse salt no I had one too I
could have dropped my croissant you had
one what I had a croissant
oh well there's no yeast in a croissant
it's just puff pastry about [ __ ] kind of
croissant
okay I'm sorry okay my turn yeah go for
it
me first you first I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go I'm gonna go okay
okay
I'm gonna start off with a real shitpost
okay oh [ __ ] what hold up what you do I
just I accidently it linked me to an
Amazon page ah okay okay it's just
pictures of them alright
okay we're gonna skip this one I'll give
it away I couldn't find an actual recipe
for it only in Amazon link I was gonna
make the buck cookies yeah yeah it look
like Vee bucks Wow
okay okay right thank you Julian okay
that is a [ __ ] pose okay two packages of
active dry yeast okay you're right it
does have yeast I thought it was puff
pastry I was gonna do okay this is my
cell phone
yeah but listen to my ingredients warm
water sweet potato white sugar
shortening egg salt flour butter bet you
didn't think there was gonna be a sweet
potato in there threw you off big time
and good high that one didn't count let
me get a recipe this is my first real
one okay right so I'm just going down
through the novel okay here we go flour
dark brown Muscovado sugar butter excuse
you
Muscovado should sugar I think musk was
the first ingredient flour flour sugar
butter pretty much mm-hmm syrup or honey
club soda sorry cinnamon ground ground
ginger egg and icing Wow
is it like a cinnamon roll close well
sort of close I don't know it has to be
some sort of baked good cuz it's sweet
and it's a pastry Oh mas what's the
cinnamon baked good I said mineral I
just guess but I'm thinking oh ah
cinnamon cookie hold on okay give you a
hint
oh good good yes good guess
I don't know it has a gender what I
don't know do you want me to tell you
which gender is it man male he he him he
him that's a he him cinnamon cookie yeah
what do you call he him him what do you
what's what is the name of a he him like
what do you he no no that he him over
there what would you say that blank
everything man okay man okay man cookie
mm man cake I'm gonna read one of the
pancake I'm gonna read one of the
ingredients again one of them again
ground ginger ground ginger man ginger
cookie man ginger cookie how does that
sentence come out of your mouth and your
bread him know the man man man or a
gingerbread lady she hurt we could have
all sorts of gingerbread
thank you gingerbread non-binary please
I'm done for all of them as long as they
got flour sugar butter ginger cinnamon
whatever else was on my Pinterest by the
way don't follow my Pinterest don't do
it okay
you know it doesn't get lost what the
farmers dog when it's on its way to your
house and your dogs are starving and
like drooling like Kermit does just so
hungry but the farmers dog they don't
get lost because it ships right to your
front door
guys the farmers dog is a service okay
that provides amazingly high-quality
food from
ingredients for your dog okay packaged
in individual pouches pre-formulated to
your specific pet or pets you go online
and you fill out the pet profile with
farmers dog you say the size of the dog
five pounds
eating habits doesn't love eating how
much they eat what's their favorite food
Marvel loves noodles right you give them
all the inside scoop about there that
there are their eating habits and they
formulate a customized plan for your dog
and they ship you the packages so that
literally you keep them in the freezer
and then the day before you're gonna
feed him put them in the fridge morning
comes rip up with a package put it in
their bowl done it's the easiest way to
feed them and they love it that's the
best part it's like they have great
energy they never ever are sick from it
they it's so easy it's so excited for
food time like peach loser there's
little tiny mind she takes me right in
my sore IT band for dinner every night
and they love it so much because it's
real food and that's what farmers dog
does is they give your pet real food
like your pet deserves they don't want
to eat kibble as much as you don't want
to feed them kibble right so farmers dog
is offering you 50% off your first two
week trial of fresh healthy food for
your pet at the farmer's dog calm that's
th e FA RM ers do G calm / - no Julian
you get free shipping check it out give
it a try let us know you think I I think
your pet will be very grateful also guys
if you want food for yourself to show up
at your front door have post mates bring
it to you
I can't even say enough good things we a
lot of times we will order food from
post mates and you are in the mood for
something different than I'm in the mood
for and I think a lot of couples or
friends I don't know through that I
can't eat Pad Thai that's a weakness of
yours not mine if she wants to have
maybe like a plate from veggie grill and
I want to have some pad thai we don't
have to fight all night about one or the
other you can just have your food and I
could have mine and mind you you know
you can also get the same food and enjoy
mm-hmm two bowls of Pad Thai or two
veggie grill plates hold my hand for
this one
or three bowls have had time and
postnatal bring it right to your house
it's really easy you can track their
location on the map so you know how long
it's gonna be until your food gets here
if you happen to shower get some stuff
done you'll be in the know and they show
up at your gate your door call you
here's your food done easy tip them on
the app it's amazing and post me is
offering you a hundred dollars of free
delivery credits for your first seven
days of using the app when you download
post mates and use code Jenna Julian
that's je n na jaql yeah check it out
you uh it's a good deal you'd be happy
to use it I think okay why did I have to
hold your hand so you say three bowls of
pad thai it was a moment ingredients one
and a half cups no sugar added apple
juice 1/2 a cup pasteurized apple cider
vinegar one and a half tablespoons raw
honey four tablespoons unflavored
gelatin guess is it a solid or liquid
this solid I guess semi solid apple
gummy bears there apple cider vinegar
honey gummies what yeah I got it yeah
before that I was gonna guess something
disgusting okay thank you for sharing no
problem
okay celery stalk oh sorry hold on man I
wish I had that recipe for review books
can't stand you you can you love
standing me no okay sorry I don't worry
about it
I got you - yeah dark roasted coffee
beans okay
water mm-hmm a coffee filter okay
a coffee machine Oh
okay coffee yeah got it good job Julian
that was just that was a [ __ ] post okay
let me do my real one okay ready
materials well ingredients julian
baker's twine okay thank you strong okay
okay
lots of round food with holes in the
middle
ie lifesavers Froot Loops Cheerios
feature especially Twizzlers cut into
smaller pieces or the Smarties with the
hole in it does it okay you're stringing
up some type of candy from the ceiling
not from the ceiling from a pole no what
okay is it a candy for that because
you're nibbled into the mic wow you did
coffee and then you guessed it though
good job alright you ready yeah yeah do
it to us eight ounces block of cream
cheese softened 2 cups shredded cheddar
cheese 2 green onions 8 Ritz crackers 8
slices of bacon half a cup of pepper
jelly what is pepper jelly just gonna
figure it out nacho cheese nachos cheese
ball is it a cheese ball nope is it
there's bacon mm-hmm cheese puffs nope
is it a cheese platter with bacon no can
you read the ingredients again two
8-ounce blocks of cream cheese oh okay
buffalo chicken dip wait
savory cheesecake mm-hmm
I already tell the cream cheese suggests
that it might be some type of dip
Mexican cheese dip what in here was
Mexican aside from the cheese the chilli
thing Ritz crackers oh that's not that's
not Mexican that's very not much it's
pepper jelly dip pepper jelly dip yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah no it's from
Louisiana
that is a [ __ ] post no it sounds good
I'm down your charge your topper jelly
dip your turn I find my turn you get
ready for this one I'm ready I'm not
curious people easy Ana they knew what
that was okay sorry I didn't mean to
offend you guys in your course I'm
offended you know you don't get to be
offended I'm so offended okay fine
you're offended I'm gonna hit you with
the real one now I'm serious this is a
real wonder okay I'm gonna start by
listing the herbs oh my god wormwood
hundred grams julian fennel 50 grams
anis 50 grams mint 15 grams of melissa 8
grams chamomile 3 grams cumin Melissa
Angelica 10 grams okay is this a Mambo
number 5 is this [ __ ] Lou Bega what
is this Oh Melissa coloring of your
choice I think green is the preferred
color and then there's four steps of
distillation and then that's the recipe
is it beer No
is it green tea no I think there might
be grip on let me see yep yep
no that's it's not green tea is it a
drink yes oh you also need green alcohol
I think yeah green alcohol 80% or above
okay
you didn't say that green alcohol 80% of
above and those herbs absinthe oh my god
how did you guess that it's green
alcohol and it's green you said pure
absence I'm not gonna high-five you for
doing absence I pinned it to my
Pinterest board so if you guys want a
recipe for pure absinthe just don't
follow me on Pinterest but you can look
there have you ever had absolute I don't
think so
even the kind that they have here isn't
the kind that's like I've had some over
Santa make you like hallucinate I've had
some overseas I didn't hallucinate
it's just like a really strong shot yeah
all right are you ready yeah
three ounces a box vanilla instant
pudding mix half a teaspoon of ground
nutmeg quarter teaspoon ground cinnamon
one and a half cups cold commercially
made eggnog half a cup bourbon or rum
eight ounces imitation whipped cream
thawed whipped cream for garnish and
nutmeg for garnish spiked nut spiked and
I ignore pretty close
Christmas alcohol pretty close what this
a bourbon version of an Irish Coffee I
don't know it's an eggnog pudding shot
oh my god that's like your literal worst
nightmare yeah that sentence is your
worst nightmare taking an eggnog
slingshot pudding shot Oh God y'all
won't get drunk off put in tonight Oh
God you that's disgusting
how do you how someone takes shots of
like thick milky substances
okay ready mm-hmm through one and a half
cups of pinhead oatmeal [ __ ] is that
fine we'll just call it oatmeal that
make you happier three and a half cups
of water 1 pinch of salt generous
oatmeal
No yes it is no it's not a meal
oats No Oh water I don't know you give
up
Oh tea oh no no that's not a thing
Oh milk oh good quick huh Oh soaked Oh
dirt Oh Oh Gert that's actually an egg
not a bad name for a note bass like it
like yogurt Oh
Oh Gert Shark Tank where you ass Oh Gert
you followed that from oats oak which I
don't
odhh soaked okay it's Scottish porridge
okay Julian what that is a shitpost
Julian that is offensive to all my Scots
out there it's not it's not a [ __ ] post
it's a authentic Scottish porridge
recipe very similar to last that last
episode ready to gruel god it's just
from Scotland Julian
mmm fine
are you ready for this recipe do it to
me Giada butter six tablespoons a
quarter cup of onion quarter cup green
bell pepper quarter cup celery two
cloves of garlic one package of frozen
crawfish one can
diced tomatoes tablespoon of cajun
seasoning 1/2 a cup of mayonnaise a cup
of shredded Monterey Jack cheese
Parmesan cheese 5 scallions 1 large loaf
of French bread a Friday night New
Orleans
crawfish what else
crawfish and bread oh my god
crawfish bread
okay like I like it yeah I'm down I mean
I don't eat cheese or crawfish but like
you know I'm down with anything like
cheese on bread down sounds good Cajun
seasoning yeah I have one not serious I
do one normal I actually like legit want
to make this okay looking boy
all-purpose flour
I'm gluten free fire if you me but
all-purpose flour xanthan gum
kosher salt cherry flavoring oil red gel
food coloring unsalted butter sugar corn
syrup sweetened condensed milk and
golden syrup like a cherry pie or
something huh I don't know I forgot the
beginning ingredients flour xantham gum
salts yeah cherry oil yeah pastry red
food coloring yeah it's a cherry pastry
finger yes it is
it's not it is a desert though oh it's
not cherry flavored I didn't say that at
all then why is the cherry oil in there
for flavoring cherry flavored yes but
it's not cherry flavored I never said
that
it's cherry flavored it's legit I never
said it wasn't
it's just not a cherry pie get your feet
off me a cherry Danish no not a baked
good hmm
they gave it away I can usually not eat
this yeah I gathered that much it has
flour in it I've ordered it online
before licorice yes
cherry well like this is what I'm making
we should make it sometime okay be fun
that would be fun I didn't realize the
licorice had flour in it it has like
wheat flour like all liquorice hmm okay
makes sense do it - yes don't talk
alright dog one gallon of water 3 cups
dark brown sugar 4 to 6 ounces spruce
tips 1 lemon 1/2 a package of champagne
yeast I don't know what that last thing
is champagne yeast can you tell me what
the literal [ __ ] that is no champagne
yeast you [ __ ] you ran a [ __ ] recipe
with Melissa as a spice in it so no I'm
not telling you it's champagne yeast is
I think you can figure it out how's your
farm
thank you can you read the ingredient
for more time no okay
is it a bowl of dirt one gallon of water
3 cups dark brown sugar 4 to 6 ounces of
spruce tips I know one lemon half a
package its Ferrero Rocher
the candy yeah the chocolate chocolate
not a candy sorry Julian had a very
in-depth debate on the Twitter stream
about why don't we get back into that
right now know whether chocolate was
candy or candy was chocolate an
interesting differences in the argument
I might write a thesis
it's spruce beer okay I should have
known with the gallon of water
what do you knew the galois other than
make [ __ ] beer what's Spruce like a
pine oak a pine beer pine beer pop beer
pub beer mmm nope a beer why does why
does Pinterest do the thing where every
time you a get the app it like reloads
the whole happen oh but it's your turn
dawg oh okay sorry
I'm ready from this website let's do it
okay ingredients sugar I'm not gonna
read in amounts unless you want it okay
sugar egg whites vanilla salt butter
melted unsweetened unsweetened cocoa
powder all purpose flour ice cream
chocolate waffle cone chocolate wafers
it's a choco taco yes it's a choco taco
in honor of choco taco it's a choco taco
you love you choco taco I'm wearing his
merch I was rainy yesterday no you don't
have as much only I do all right beat
you ready mm-hmm
six cups of potatoes mashed potatoes one
No Oh one cup of cheddar cheese 3/4 cup
mayonnaise one cup of bacon three
teaspoons of garlic half a cup of onion
it's baked potato from Wendy's mm-hmm no
mashed potato because it calls for six
cup potato skins six cups of potatoes
mashed potatoes french fries with with
mayo mayo fries deep-fried mayo with
potatoes on top
not a bad guess what is it it's called
Mississippi mud potatoes why what why I
give you easy ones like absent all right
I got one that you probably get the
recipe has so it won't open
okay okay baby marble all right Julian
vegetable oil 1 cup dill pickle chips 1
cups buttermilk 1.5 chuckles what kind
deep-fried pickles copycat hooters nice
yeah I should put on a hooters you know
get up and I can make you some fried
pickles and give you if you want it ya
can objectify me in a little bit okay
I'm down okay cool
we'll make a vlog out of it sounds tight
no he won't
okay you ready this is okay this is the
only recipe that I picked that I think
you'd actually like want to eat right
okay 300 thousand grams of pasta
okay so just 300 grams of pasta one tray
of fresh uni that is yeah it's a sea
urchin nice well then I don't need to
touch hands with you butter room
temperature not cold olive oil
miso garlic it's that dream pasta that
one egg Oney Oh Don togarashi no
togarashi crushed nori and salt
you know it's oniy pasta yeah sea urchin
pasta with with uni miso butter just
about whatever that is don't oh I can't
look at it oh my god those are like the
little balls I don't know what those are
are those fish eggs yeah oh I'm gonna
vom I'm gonna vom I'm gonna don't I
can't like look you can touch it and
feel the texture
like it actually makes me nauseous
are you done but now I'm gonna vom okay
okay I have some more for you you ready
give me give me to me to me to me
one and a quarter cup of sugar a half a
cup of oil 3 tablespoons of citrus juice
deep-fried lemonade that's it that's it
oil citrus juice and sugar mm-hmm syrup
its syrup syrup
what's in oil fried sugar mm-hmm is it
fried mm-hmm is a liquid no technically
not sweet oil mm-hmm swell syrup that's
a syrup it's not scary it's is it triple
sec no is it um it's just oil what do
you mean it's oil with two other things
citrus lemon oil oil with lemon oil
poured on top of lemon and sugar oil and
lemon and sugar don't smile like that
give me a hint
you sharking your
is not a hint is the opposite of it it
smells like lemon lemon pledge no is it
a cleaning product no oil are you ready
yeah it's a leg scrub that's not a
recipe it is a recipe that's not a rest
in your body
I looked up scrub recipe okay
sorry you didn't get it okay my turn for
doing that my turn
tequila vodka rum triple sec gin lemon
juice ah jungle juice no wait read it
again tequila vodka rum triple sec gin
lemon juice oh that's like a Long Island
I see it's the kitchen cabinet dude yeah
okay mmm here you go Julianne doing it
to half a cup of creamy peanut butter
1/4 cup honey 1 tablespoon of coconut
oil cup of chicken broth cup of rolled
oats cup of whole wheat flour cup of
all-purpose flour ok what ok restart
please half a cup of creamy peanut
butter half a cup of honey 1 tablespoon
of coconut oil a cup of chicken broth
that's where you lost me rolled oats 1
cup of whole wheat flour 1 cup of
all-purpose flour peanut butter oat
fried chicken no there's no chicken it's
just chicken broth that's somehow worse
butter soup chicken ice chicken soup
flavored ice cubes topped with peanut
butter who do you think this recipe dog
that's a dog food recipe wolf is it like
a lick or like just a soup for them
no it's flour oh so it's like a baked do
you bake it mm-hmm Oh God so it's like a
doggie little it's a biscuit that
reminds me of when we made I'm pretty
sure we followed a recipe very similar
to that when we made them biscuits and
they loved it hello what's going on a
recipe I have it's a video oh it's
frozen okay um I don't know what to do
here I'm gonna close the app my app
froze okay um I'm gonna try to click at
the end Oh read it there's a reading
there's a read it version wait one sec
what is going on I'm doing my next
recipe okay here we go here we go ready
one of the ingredients is gonna give it
completely away but I'm gonna do it at
the end plastic knife small mixing bowl
petroleum jelly an EOS container is it
slime no a cotton bud vanilla vitamin E
capsule capsule coconut oil beeswax
that's that's the list of ingredients
for
yep that's it what do you got what's
here guys is it a homemade chapstick
close lip balm
what is that cupcake it was a really
bright and colorful DIY video on it and
it sucked me in so I wait is it so it's
a lip balm cuz it's just petroleum and
vitamin E but it's a cupcake because
somebody put sprinkles in it yeah that's
disgusting oh is it a cupcake oh I see I
see
well it isn't a cupcake yeah it's a
little lip balm but I imagine DIY
cupcake us
that's so misleading it's like a cupcake
looking eos but it's not an actual
edible cupcake that looks like an EOS so
I could click on this video and not know
better and make that thing eat it
Julianne it's clearly not food DIY
cupcake AOS I mean put cupcake in the
summer on the title and not give me a
cupcake that's a quick way and you're in
the kitchen looking at a thing in
petroleum going man I just never knew
that was a cupcake damn it's a
weird-looking cupcake okay one and a
half cups of flour one cup of rolled
oats a tablespoon of baking powder half
a teaspoon of salt a quarter cup of
sugar one egg milk 1/4 cup of coconut
oil half a cup of honey and a cup of
dandy line dandelion flower petals Merry
Christmas
some [ __ ] Bates good with flower
petals on it is it bread yeah it is
it's bright it's a kind of bread Oh corn
bread no is there corn in it
no is there flowers on topper inside
there inside
well peach is dreaming wonder what she's
dreaming about Shay go ask her aloud
dream BG
is it as growling why she growling move
your mic towards her I wanna see we can
hear it you want to raise Jenna's mic
whenever you try to listen to your dog
having a dream is when they stop having
a dream alright umm I don't know is it
some sort of like Brazilian sweet bread
or something a muffin oh that's much
simpler okay what kind of muffin a
dandelion muffin from Montana I don't
care
YUM am i right did you ever eat
dandelions no they're good no we're not
good yeah okay I got one
supplies bolt cutters and saw wrench
metal rod nuts washers and lock washers
to fit a 1/4 inch four threaded rods
heavy-duty felt pads for feet pieces of
MDF for the board's piping gel candy
melts food color gels small rolling pin
offset spatula tylose powder trends and
tool dressed into a flexible fondant
smoother fondant modeling chocolate foil
tape circle cutters sugar shapers
fondant ribbon cutter six wheel pastry
cutter a Tony Hawk cake
close all the fondant like you're making
something on top of a cake or something
like that
close this could also be like a Tony
Hawk cake at a child's birthday party a
Tony Hawk cupcake
no it's not Tony Hawk nor okay actually
way no it is a cake sorry this cake it
is a game not a Tony Hawk cake okay
a minion cake no no keep going
spider-man you kissing I don't know I
can't see what is it for a night llama
caked so you did v bucks cookies and a
fortnight llama cake I'm a fortnight er
what do you want
come on that looks cool look look at the
cross-section here so yeah that is so
cool so da is really [ __ ] right this
was done so well though like I mean this
yeah this would take me eight hundred
[ __ ] times and it would come out
looking like [ __ ] well the first 799 it
would eight hundred that would come
really good-looking great okay I'm out
of recipes just oh I got one good one
for dessert to top us off ready for
dessert finish us off we do we not just
have dessert with that fortnight-long
that was the main of course let me just
get through the novel here okay here we
go butter onion celery carrots one ham
bone diced ham split you just had to
write it like that split peas six cups
of chicken stock 2 bay leaves kosher
salt
split pea soup why do they have the
right split peas because that's what
they are they could have just wrote peas
secret style split pea soup well take a
bowl of split pea soup and serve
yourself and move out of my way because
I'm having some next you don't even like
soup I don't like soup at all nor do I
like split pea soup in fact if I were to
choose one soup to literally never eat
it's good split pea soup
yeah how dare you I like all soup I know
you do
so you're biased split pea soup to me
well except for gross seafood soup
not interested um split pea soup is
gross no it's not family come me out of
here No
peas are good I don't I don't agree with
you at all no I'll give you soup can be
good chicken noodle soup ramen like hot
sour soup yep even like a when I was
younger I would have like like a clam
chowder it was good mm-hmm so soup is
good but not every sip please split pea
soup get out of here you're not at
liberty to say cuz I don't think you've
ever had it you don't think I've ever
had split pea soup how about this ready
I'm gonna drop a bomb on you I have had
it there you go
what do you need you know that's my mom
and my brother they know okay I'll see
you brother tomorrow ask him he's not
gonna know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about
cuz you're lying no I had split pea soup
and I don't enjoy it good morning
morning see now is an appropriate time
to put your hand near him because he
just saw what was coming at him all
right Julian you want some farmers Dunc
he does he loves it well good job good
job okay don't all right we're done here
thank you guys we're listening to the
podcast hopefully you enjoyed listening
us listening to us list off recipes and
improperly guessed them all day it was
fun I hope you had a good time don't
make any of these if you want anyone who
lives with you to still like you except
for the fortnight bee bop cookies
definitely make those that's good that's
a good way to become the favorite
roommate in the house
anyway we'll see you guys next mummy
thank you for hanging out for another
episode that you've been listening to
you for watching thank you sponsors Wow
yeah we'll catch you later